يوم الجمعه الاخيره من شهر يناير بدات
رحله منطاد الازمه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده
وفق التقديرات فان المنطاد عبر المحيط
الهادئ دخل الاجواء الامريكيه فوق ولايه
الاسكا بعد 24 ساعه امضى السبت والاحد في
اجواء الاسكا ثم دخل المجال الجوي الكندي
يوم الاثنين دخل المنطاد المجال الجويه
الامريكي مره اخرى في اجواء ولايه ايداه
يوم الثلاثاء بدات فكره اسقاطه لكن
المسؤولين الامريكيين لم يتمكنوا من تحديد
المخاطر على الناس اليوم الاول من الشهر
الحالي دخل المنطاد واجواء مونتانا وحلق
بالقرب من قاعده الجويه تضم القاعده
العديد من قواعد الصواريخ النوويه رسد من
المدنيين واغلق المطار الدولي مؤقتا هنا
اذن الرئيس الامريكي باسقاط المنطاد دون
مخاطر على الناس بعد يوم كشف المسؤولون
الامريكيون ان المنطاد كان يح فوق البر
الرئيسي للولايات المتحده لعده ايام بعد
اسبوع على انطلاق المنطاد من الصين رصده
مدنيون اثناء تحليقه فوق
هنا اعترفت الصين بالمنطاد لكنها قالت انه
مخصص للطقس وانحرف عن مساره معتذره
للولايات المتحده عن دخوله الاجواء
الامريكيه بالخطا في اليوم التالي اتخذ
القرار بتنفيذ عمليه الاسقاط غادر المنطاد
البر الامريكي اثناء تحليقه فوق المحيط
الاطلسي قباله ساحلي ولايه كارولاينا
الجنوبيه تكفلت طائره اف 22
بمواجهه المنطاد على ارتفاع يتراوح بين 18
و19 كيلومترا اطلقت الاف 22 صاروخا انفجر
قربا المنطاد وحرقه وسقط اعلن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي انه لم تسجل اي اضرار جانبيه او
خسائر في عمليه الاسقاط الامنه بالتنسيق
مع الحكومه الكنديه رد المبالغ فيه وينتهك
الممارسات الدوليه تعليق الخارجيه على
العمليه هكذا يبدو ان ازمه المنطاد في
شكلها التقني والعسكري قد انتهت لكنها على
الاغلب لم تنتهي في شكلها السياسي بين
بلدين يسود التوتر العلاقه بينهما
[موسيقى]